sabemos que el plástico es uno de los
grandes problemas que afectan a los
océanos por ejemplo según el fondo
mundial para la naturaleza
anualmente el mundo produce más de 200
millones de toneladas de desechos
plásticos y más de 11 millones de ellas
llegan a los océanos cada vez más países
se han sumado a regulaciones contra este
material pero porque al día de hoy
siguen siendo insuficientes
muchas gracias de parte de punto se más
arriba es realmente un honor estar con
ustedes esta noche el problema de la
contaminación por plásticos el problema
la contaminación marina por desechos
plásticos es un problema de dinámica
global
y definitivamente por eso es que las
mejores respuestas y las respuestas más
eficientes van a venir de la mano de una
cooperación internacional regional y a
nivel mundial el plástico se produce en
diferentes lugares se gestiona se
consume en otros
la dinámica es compleja y además el
plástico es un material que está
totalmente
sentado en la base de la forma en la que
nos desarrollamos consumimos y nos
transportamos el plástico su material es
esencial en todo lo que nosotros hacemos
de ahí que los cambios sean tan
complejos y sean de tantos retos es un
reto de primer orden y recientemente
estas decisiones regionales como los de
los estados del pacífico nordeste
abordar el problema la contaminación de
forma cooperada y de forma cooperativa a
nivel regional y la decisión además hace
algunos meses de los estados en en la
asamblea las naciones para de las
naciones unidas para el medio ambiente
para abordar este problema a través de
un convenio internacional nuevo
jurídicamente vinculante son las
respuestas definitivamente más efectivas
a este problema estructural y que a
nivel de los océanos se manifiesta de
las peores formas señor que es ahora
aparte del plástico con que otras
cuestiones o problemas afectan a los
océanos de américa y que debe hacer para
que debe hacerse para acabar con ellos
es urgente la regulación es urgente
reconocimiento de los estados de nuestra
región es volver la vista a nuestros
espacios marinos a nuestros espacios
costeros la sobreproducción la
sobreexplotación la sobrepesca es una
son uno de los grandes flagelos que
tienen nuestros espacios marinos y
costeros
ahora esto no es un tema únicamente de
los gobiernos cuál es el mensaje que
usted le da a los ciudadanos de a pie
para que se apropien de esta
problemática muy brevemente por favor
desde fundación marviva hemos compartido
un mensaje desde hace muchos años chau
plástico desechable la oportunidad que
tenemos como personas es disminuir
nuestro uso y consumo de un material que
es difícilmente reciclable y
difícilmente biodegradable